I'm back again I'm gonna show you a
really cool technique it's basically a
skull massage now this is not like other
skull massages that you might see on the
Internet
this is basically working on this suture
right through in here it's called a
sagittal suture a suture is a joint now
this joint is in some people it's fused
and some people there's still some
fibrous tissue in there that can expand
very very very very tiny amounts but
what you're gonna do is you're gonna
basically take your thumb and you can
start here and this is the back we're
looking at the top of the skull right
here and I'll walk you through it but
basically start back here and we inch
forward slowly and we're pressing this
way from back to front slowly and I'll
show you the amount of time that you
need to do this as well because we're
going to demonstrate this so why does
this work I have no idea all I know is
it's gonna make someone feel really good
I've done this in my practice thousands
and thousands of times and it really
gives people a lot of relief it'll help
them sleep it'll actually help them
breathe better it reduces stress you
just have to try it you do need another
person to do this on you because you
can't do this to yourself because you
have to be fully relaxed while you're
doing it using the chair and I'm gonna
walk you through it
right now check this out okay so I'm
gonna show you on a person but let me
just first show you on my friendly
skeleton right here you can see the
suture here there's one right here that
comes up right here you're gonna be
taking your thumb okay and you're gonna
be coming forward this way okay slowly
you're just gonna kind of use traction
to go forward and you're gonna hold that
okay you're gonna hold the front of the
forehead with the other hand and we're
gonna press these together and gingerly
slowly inch up this way okay and I'll
show you on the person but this is kind
of what you're doing you're just kind of
creating a kind of a base or more
relaxation along this line right here
okay so that's what you're doing all the
way to the front right here let's show
you on an actual person but we have the
sutures that one that goes right up the
center there's one
right here there's one right here so
you're gonna take your hand stabilize
the forehead and you take your thumb
right here and we'll start right here
and we want to push forward okay so like
four we're gonna inch our thumb forward
through here and we're just gonna hold
this and apply traction and just hold
that pressure just like this so I'm
pressing forward like this okay so I'm
taking you that there's some slight
pressure on the skull but I'm actually
going forward like this I just want you
to see the subtle subtleness right
through here so I'm gonna hold this for
a little bit and I'm supporting the
skull
now I'm gonna inch forward right down
the center as I'm following that suture
the most important thing is you don't
mess up the hair because you're gonna
really upset Steve now the only time
that you wouldn't do this is if someone
actually got hit on top of the head and
that would be painful because you don't
want to press on an old injury so I'm
kind of slowly inching forward like this
kind of like doing this and he should
feel like the head is relaxing the skull
is relaxing in theory feels terrific
good and if you had injury to your head
let's say on the left or the right this
is essential there's a small amount of
connective tissue that that is in this
joint right here of course when you're a
baby there's a space there and then it
closes down pretty good I mean there's a
chance that it's probably it could be
fused as well but now what I'm doing is
my thumb is getting sore so I'm gonna
bend it up here and help with this thumb
and press it forward like this you see
what I'm doing there that feels really
good yeah and I'm just inching forward
probably a couple minutes giving it hit
in the head steep well it's a little kid
you know my if you shave my head it
looks like the moon from all the rocks
on the corner of the coffee table but
right no serious injuries I guess
stitches yes now my getting towards this
area right through here
good how's that feel oh just fabulous
not really good really relaxed yeah you
did all the work exactly now I just have
to kind of make your hair so that's the
simply how you do it start here inch
forward slowly go forward that's all you
need to do go ahead and try it put your
comments below
hey if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos